demain sourire à oslo la conférence
internationale contre le travail des
enfants une nouvelle fois l' esclavage
des petits mise en évidence malgré les
lois et les conventions qui se
multiplient des millions d'enfants
seraient réduits à l'état d'esclaves un
peu partout dans le monde nathalie
moison
images d'un autre âge
le calvaire des enfants esclaves des
mines de charbon c'est aujourd'hui en
colombie
plusieurs parents ont décidé d'aider ces
enfants ravier a passé cinq ans dans
cette mine aujourd'hui il va à l'école
ravier quand tu retournes dans la mine à
quoi ça te fait penser
quand tu es dans la mine
toute petite pause
n'y en a pas parce que c'est tellement
fatiguant le patron te pousse à
continuer
c'est dur alors tu te dis mais pourquoi
diable
un enfant comme moi fait travailler
comme ça là
dans cette tannerie égyptienne les
enfants travaillent à proximité des
barriques de produits dangereux pour
l'unicef ils sont 250 millions dans le
monde à mettre en danger leur santé ou à
risquer leur vie au travail
certains diront que nous devons nous
attaquer la pauvreté en priorité car
c'est la cause du travail des enfants
mais on ne peut pas attendre sur la
question du travail dangereux les
gouvernements et le public aussi doivent
se soulever contre les dangers un
travail des enfants
soustraire les enfants aux risques de
maladie c'est la priorité de l'unicef
ainsi dans cette usine indienne où l'on
poli le diamant le travail laisse les
enfants admis aveugle ou malades des
poumons d'axa n'a que 14 ans son
certificat de naissance le prouve
l'embarras de son patron le confirme
pourquoi vous l'employez 14 ans c'est
trop jeune
c'est la pauvreté
comment vous l'expliquez
sempéré pauvres très pauvres
les enfants du tiers-monde fabrique
également des chaussures des chemises ou
des vêtements pour de grandes marques
occidentales
la conférence d'oslo aura aussi pour but
d'attirer l'attention des consommateurs
que nous sommes sur ses pratiques
et à bruxelles